what kind of work do you do before
working on a screenplay
what's the pre-work coming up with ideas
which we talked about a few different
ways
to try and do that um
outlining is again like for me outlining
is the most important process again it
might not be for other people
is for me i have to outline and hammer
that story out
before i even start page one of any
script whether it be tv or feature or
short or whatever um
so that's yeah that's my pre-processes
first coming when i when i first and i
come up with ideas
different ways some of them are from
dreams i've had
some of them are from watching other
movies or
reading other scripts or doing the comp
game of combining things like that
i actually was reading at least i've
been reading some of the blacklist
scripts and i've actually come up with
two ideas
in the last couple days that sprung out
of my head
from other scripts that i was reading
that have nothing to do with the scripts
i was reading
but something that they said in the
script tweaked an idea i was like oh
that would be a really cool like
what if i use like this line that they
use but then that strikes this whole new
concept you know
um it's like one of them like uh the the
mountain climbing
movie i was talking about haunted
mountain so they you know they're they
um she's along with climbing mountain
her her team with her is basically
making a documentary about her
um you know so you've got like a bit of
a found footage like going back and
forth being like some phone footage and
real life stuff
um so i was like okay well what if we
had took that found footage
aspect of it and we had somebody you
know also
the point of the movie of the the
mountain climbing thing is it's a
mountain that no one's ever climbed i'm
like okay well we have somebody
going going or doing something that no
one's ever done before and getting it
all on camera
and then i'm like oh what if we made it
a long distance space
travel movie and we take an elon musk
type character who's invented this brand
new
uh method of space travel and he's gonna
be the one to test it out he's getting
everything on footage and
boom had nothing to do with that script
other than
there's cameras involved and going
somewhere no one's ever gone before
so that came out of that idea and then i
read another script
about um it was it was a pilot i think
um no it was a movie it was a movie and
i'm coming up with a pilot uh
the idea i had was a pilot where the uh
the guy
they were they had this um technology
where they were
able to go into it was a uh i can't
remember the name of the movie they're
the script there's no blacklist script
it was a soldier who she had ptsd
and they were trying to like fix her
ptsd by
having instead of having regular therapy
sessions like this they came up with
this vr
scenario situation where they had taken
um all of the uh
audio footage of like the specific
um mission that she was on that kind of
triggered
the ptsd and she was having to relive it
but she was realizing that there were
things wrong
with the thing like they had some of
their their facts wrong like
who went into the building first they
had wrong and they had like um
the color of a building right like some
minor stuff that seemed minor and but
later on the script became major things
so from that i came up with the idea of
oh well what if we have a tv series a
detective show
where they have this technology to
basically rebuild the crime scene in a
virtual world and go in there
and take different people's like the
different eyewitness testimonies and
then the different
like the splatter tests whatever and
they can rebuild the entire thing and
then see how the crime actually happened
i'm like that's in my head that seems
like a cool idea show that i would watch
you know i don't know i'm not sure how
many seasons i would watch
but but it's at least a cool little idea
came from just like a piece of
technology you know so i come up with
come up with story ideas from pretty
much anywhere uh either so i've seen
stuff i've done
dreams i write the ideas down in my idea
book where i
have at this point literally hundreds of
tv and movie ideas i think the last time
i actually counted it was 212.
um but that's it's just like a little
one sentence thing
some cases it's like just a title of
something that popped in my head
and whenever i need something new to
write i go through there
try to figure out what seems like viable
ideas right now what actually sounds fun
to write right now because not every
idea you have is going to be something
fun um
sometimes it's like big cool action
stuff and you want to write those and
sometimes it's like
very small personal dramatic indie type
stuff
you know that it might not be in the
mood for right now because it's going to
depress the hell out of you while you're
writing it
so find something that sounds good i
want to write then i spend time actually
coming up with okay here's the one
sentence where's the story in that
doing my outlining process for that i do
all my outlining by hand
i find it much easier for the ideas to
flow when i'm sitting there writing it
out again my handwriting is so bad
that sometimes i can't read it
afterwards but i do my best
um and then i'll go through
either rereading it in there making
changes in the notebook or
typing it all up and then realizing oh
this doesn't work and it can change
things
from the typed up version of the outline
and hammering it out till it's
bulletproof
and then i write the first draft of the
script that was a very long answer for
that question i apologize
what do writers get wrong with the first
10 pages of a screenplay
not being interesting uh i've seen too
many people have flashbacks in the first
couple of pages that's what
it'll start with the flat what are you
flashbacking from if that's if that's
the first thing you're having happen
that doesn't make any sense um not
giving us enough about the character
we're gonna be following
like a lot of a lot of horror especially
you know we'll start off with
something that's has to do with like the
killer like how they're killing people
but there's nothing with the characters
we're actually following you know so
it's like a little
teaser thing so it does its job in
telling us okay this is what the movie's
gonna be about
we still don't even know who we're gonna
be following so i feel like in the first
10 pages you need to have
who we're going to be following what the
story is going to be about
be interesting for the love of god um
and give us some some reason to turn the
page to go on to the next
uh pages and the rest of the script
did you like guardians of the galaxy the
first one i loved it the second one not
so much
why um i feel like they went too
big with the second movie um and then
couldn't wrap it up in a way that made
any sense
um they also i felt like in the first
movie did like a really good job
of taking the humor
and the action and the drama and mulling
them together in a good way
in the second movie i felt like they
went way too much with the funny
because they like that was what they
were banking on from the first movie was
that it was a superhero movie that was
kind of a comedy
and now they added too much comedy and
went too big with who the villain was
and they could never
get back to the main core of the story
and they kept the main characters apart
for too long
before they brought them back together
so it was like their character dynamics
they weren't able to play off of each
other because they were suddenly not the
same scenes anymore
and so all the stuff that worked really
well in the first scene the character
dynamics the comedy
um you know a medium level of
threat for them they just kind of like
went off and
off the handles and and lost track of
everything in that second movie
on the flip side what about sicario the
first one not even
not okay okay so we want as i was gonna
ask what what
what do you think sometimes is the
breakdown between the first
one is it because the the first film
of of a trilogy or whatever is is
um is a new world it's fresh the
characters
are interesting because we want to get
to know them but then we tire of them or
and i'm not saying that happened with
sicario surely i don't see
either of them so i have no opinion on
that movie whatsoever
oh that's a cool title um
i would say that going from an original
movie to the sequel
the problem okay well
i feel like because you you need to
follow it up with something that's a
little bit bigger because the the whole
point of any
movie is rising stakes throughout the
course of it you know you're starting
with someone who's in their regular
normal world
and then with their lives and so
going from the first movie to a second
movie you want to keep that
going but i feel like the two big
pitfalls of a sequel
is either a it goes too far
um where it's like a huge leaps and
bounds beyond what the first movie was
and it's
how did they get there from here like
that's such a huge
jump or they don't have
even as big of stakes where they kind of
like pull it back a little bit too much
um i don't know that we get necessarily
tired with the characters
per se like i will watch every marvel
movie that ever comes out for the rest
of my life because it's
cool and i love it but i and i'm not
getting tired of the characters
because they are keeping it fresh with
the types of situations that the
characters are in
same thing goes with television series
you know they're constantly getting
like more and more dramatic or bigger
and badder characters and they're
different types of characters
that they're having to face uh i
mentioned the flash earlier like
the problem with like the first three
seasons of the flash
the bad guy was always another speedster
so he's just going against somebody who
has the exact same power set as him
so then with later seasons they started
giving him characters who had totally
different power sets so i think was like
two seasons ago maybe
possibly three they had uh the thinker
was his bad guy
you know where his hit the bat the
thinkers superpower is just
figuring out everything like five ten
steps ahead of the flash knowing
everything that's gonna happen
and can set up all the dominoes so they
fall exactly the way he wants it
um and then you know so it's like
something that
flash couldn't beat that because he's
really really fat he's a smart guy
because you know he he works uh for the
the police department you know in the
forensics department so he's a smart
dude
but his thing is think is moving really
fast so how does he compete with
somebody who is
thinking everything you could possibly
do no matter how fast you move he knows
all the possibilities
and has set up you know based on that so
it needs to keep changing and evolving
as opposed to just being the same story
over and over but you need to make sure
to not go too
far with the evolution to the point that
it's not realistic anymore
you